but on move nine white's only developed
piece is a king
but white's also up two pieces so it's a
fascinating position
that's another reason why i love the
stafford
oh i'm playing fidel shout out to fidel
who's also streaming
people should check out fidel on twitch
let's play a stafford against fidel
he probably knows what to do
there's a youtube video where he falls
into my stafford trap
oh oh he's playing this move let's have
some fun
oh he knows what to do why is he going
into this
what's the line here
to remember the line
like queen i think it's casting actually
i know king e3 is castling i assume the
same as with king f3
it's a cool variation
the king's just on e4 the question is
how to proceed
it's something like queen h4 and rook e8
yeah i've it's been a while since i
studied this
this is like one theory in this position
so queen h4 king f3
oh no it's um queen h4 king f3 and then
[Music]
uh here and then g4 i take and then
i remember this now okay
yeah king of three i think is the only
move and then i skewer
g4 only move and then i take takes and i
take this way and then
f5 in the end and there's a way to play
for a win
um wait rookie eight
rookie a king
how to do this
i have to start with rookie 8.
i have at least do i have a draw i don't
know
[Music]
chuck where's my wind
let's try this and then
not entirely sure
a crazy line though
you just queen of two
because queen f3 i've queen e1
that's burned a lot of time there i'm
also threatening
a rook coming in i'm down two pieces
though
i'm down two pieces uh
check check
please work not so sure about this
though
there's bishop d2
um it's not quite working
and the king's on c3
yeah it's a little bit too slow
i'm still fighting
i'm gonna go for e5
i have to use my pawns
i mean a5 is kind of annoying move for
white and the knight's
very much stuck which means the rook is
stuck
tricky
oh now the knight is unstuck i want to
play c5
[Music]
hitting the bishop also threatening to
take in here
wow cool move bro
it's taking this move
so i'm turning the vision and this
it's complicated and that's what i want
so i'm finding c6 now
oh check
not getting anything
i thought i was getting something
can i sack everything in stalemates
stop hurting me
he misforced me there
ah he found force mates oh what a cool
game
that was a cool game gg fidel
uh i almost fought back
and this this comes down to like very
concrete variations
i didn't think this was a good line for
white but maybe it's playable
oh maybe it's just a draw
oh bishop g4 is a move oh here's a
perpetual
queen c5 and then i move back
yeah because i'm down two pieces so
playing for a win doesn't quite work out
in my favor
yeah fidel got revenge
but this is a line like for a lot of
players
if you go into this against a grand
master and you you at least know
how to like get the repetition a draw is
still a decent result
and it's such a funny musician too after
after how many moves so on move nine
oh engine doesn't like king e4 but on
move nine
white's only developed piece is a king
but white's also up two pieces so it's a
fascinating position
it's another reason why i love the
stafford
um what should i do here
yeah maybe there's some other like weird
engine moves
i was remembering the line if g4
then i would take take and then take on
h1
i basically have rook and two pawns for
three pieces
three minor pieces and then idea f5
anyway if that goes on youtube already
envisioning the thumbnail
the thumbnail of like the king on e4